[Music]
in mega fight news luminal ID this
McGregor vs. Mayweather oh my gosh okay
I'm waiting for this day okay this guy I
love that guy he's been training I've
been watching a trade lat Hartman and
Vine submitted by Neal the flack a fight
between Conor McGregor employed
Mayweather is officially gonna happen
yeah I feel like it's too early I mean
Reapers me I want to see this now but I
still think it's too early how in what
regard could make whoever's been
fighting and boxing for like way way
longer than the cracker oh I don't I
know that they want to fight and even
one in fact but are they fighting and
then they started going to fight
mayweather and boxing um the only
mayweather does have way more experience
which counts for a lot but one thing
that makes me feel good is a Dana White
used to be a boxing promoter before he
got into enemy so and he boxed himself
and so for him to actually support this
move I think that says a lot and he also
says Mayweather has never hit anyone
and has never fought anyone that hits as
hard as McGregor hmm well initially Dana
White didn't want to do this fight I
think that's for money reasons but now
he's saying that it was just to money
too much money to pass up on
I think it's money reasons because
before he doesn't want to risk injuring
or losing one of his biggest ticket
sales people write to another like
Federation or League but now if there's
a way to work itself out and he's also
in the mix of this deal like he somehow
wedged his way into this deal so he's
going to be able to profit off of this I
think it was a money issue the whole
time good up his job to the promoter so
I think if he's the modern-day like Don
King of MMA of course he's not going to
want to let Mike Tyson gold fight MMA or
judo or some other random [ __ ] he's not
an ability to get money from but now
that he's able to that thing is going to
support
but just to give some perspective though
the type of money he's going to make
from just fighting is way crazier than
what he would make an MMA if you wanna
know
win or lose one in MMA and win or lose
in the US yes yes so like if you money
is here and I'm a money's right down
here
yeah boxing money is like like bring in
30 million 20 yeah well it's with me
whether uh I mean it's a worldwide sport
it is but then I think like MMA is hella
popular in the US but boxing is it's
like soccer it's worldwide that boxing
has legacy it's just been around for a
lot longer so any sport that has been
obviously has more sponsorship and is
deeper and then those connections so for
example you know you have like these
smaller fights right for us when we see
things we think that these guys are
getting pain mills it's not true Nate
for example make Diaz right when he
fought McGregor on that second time
around that's the first time he ever
broke into seven figures prior to that
he was making 20km fight 20k a fight by
the way it's on the upper echelon if
you're not if you're not one of those
huge neighbors like Anderson Silva
they're making 20k fights it's not much
money
yeah the UFC just started maybe not what
are you feeling I mean that's why you
always hear fighters going up pay me now
I want my money they're not walking away
with the [ __ ] kind of money they're
walking away with 20 G's 30 G's 15 GS
these lower tier fighters that you see
when it's just like a few people on the
crowd they're walking away with like 2
grand 3 grand pocket cash and then they
spend like five g's on hospital bills
exactly yeah it's even I think not to
knock boxing but I think in MMA there's
way more injuries and risks you know
because you know it's all your legs are
success
I think made Diaz from what I read from
the Conor McGregor fight he walked away
just from the fight alone with 7 mil
right he has been fighting since he was
in a teenager and this is the first time
he actually made something worth
fighting for his whole face is all
[ __ ] up for crying out loud and then
offer like the pay-per-view and the ad
tells you like another like 6 mil on top
of that yesterday him so it was great
for him you know what I mean and so
that's why I McGregor now
McGregor is a fight or two he doesn't
to like defend a title he's not like a
Demetrius Johnson to make sure his
Johnson he had defended his title over
ten times so he's somebody who wants to
dominate his weight class I think what I
see from McGregor is that he wants the
next challenge next challenge next time
then your [ __ ] where he goes it's about
the money and the challenge so that's
why he wants to go he wants to fight
mayweather number one it's because it's
going to pay him a lot he's going to get
eight figures all aboard yes sir like
way more than way more that he was going
to get anywhere to me Oh CJ lately said
and it's win-win
I think Mayweather if he lost for
Harrington you got beat by a MMA fighter
and so for him like I think that it's
almost lose-lose for Mayweather
but for McGregor if you did lose he
always has to back up well MMA fighters
fighting something else not only coming
up with so much more money they're
talking about if he winner loses this
one like it would be like his biggest
payout yeah yeah it's going to be huge
for my even reputation wise he would
lose nothing because he fought in
something else
he's still an MMA champion so I think
it's win-win for me on McGregor and I
think it's like a no-brainer friend
right he's going to make like 30 mil or
something like that something crazy it
was high because he enjoys it but the
initial offer of like 20 mil wasn't
enough yeah because I mean animate at
the max he's getting like low seven
figures or mid seven figures or
something like that for the fight with
Nate he got like a mil more than naked
so I think he got like 14 or 15 okay and
I was like super [ __ ] high you know
so prior to that there's like people who
are making like I think the first person
to make a mil I mean I can correct me if
I was like Tito Ortiz he was the first
one to get like those huge big numbers
because at the time he was a huge star
yeah you even tie it yeah so it's pretty
insane man like I'm super excited to see
the fight number one like Mayweather was
forty nine and zero
undefeated 49 in general idea is right
how is she fought back kill earlier
though yeah cuz I feel like man it would
have been weird locked away from that
pecky I win a lot two hundred and fifty
million dollars 215 million Oh wonderful
waters wrong with guys
yes promotion company everything so he's
making money not as just a fighter but
laughing motor still a lot of [ __ ]
money
he was just an athlete he probably still
walk away were like what 40 or something
like that I don't know everybody has an
opinion on the fight like Mayweather
obviously hasn't lost he's highly
defensive you know and there's a lot
more rules especially like with in
Boston compared to any just a fighter
though he's an artist he takes his time
but is it going to watch but Mayweather
is also looking he's getting older now
and the economy grows young and the
energy levels different rivers 28
Mayweather's 40 and Mayweather has been
on a 23 months of retirement yeah this
full-time self he just started training
though I saw his videos doesn't mean he
sloppy as [ __ ] though I know I
personally don't know which way it's
going to be undefeated so even here's my
with ring rust he'll still kick everyone
off today yeah yeah yeah I mean he's not
entertaining like Mike Tyson or the
greats
I feel like Mayweather is just a really
calm smart fighter what's going to
happen there's like Conor McGregor my
personal opinion he has to go for a
knockdown he's not gonna want to points
look at the one foots what may want to
do something that happens he has nothing
else out
oh is this a day are they pretty close
to wait oh they're very close to wait
and then I saw that Mayweather brought
in this young boxer so he could steal
the energy of a young kid and so he's
already training with someone else like
hell already when it is natural so it's
been announced that the site will be on
August 26
9 mega Wow the top I won't have a baby
then ralpherz not gonna watch it
that's so you could watch it on his
phone this is now haha King history in
the making this has never happened ever
yeah oh my god and then they're both I
said [ __ ] Tucker to it can be really and
the styles are so different like one guy
stinking conservative and the other guy
doesn't give a [ __ ] any moves
[ __ ] all weird and [ __ ] it's going to
be such a good fight Wow did he have any
background in boxing at all yeah he does
McGregor yeah yeah
oh yes background there's no way if he
helped me he would never dearly everyone
and then a has a bathroom ambassador oh
it's almost impossible oh wow he trained
boxing but I think he actually was like
a boxer boxer like I think he did fight
in boxing and stuff oh wow dude I see
MMA fighters like human Swiss Army man
in terms of like fighting machines so
many different styles yeah like you know
everything now I have a I had the UFC
fight pass and so you could watch old
matches like it's amazing how much it
has evolved it's weird like people like
you watch from like literally ten years
ago they look slow as [ __ ] and it looks
like the game is so one-sided like back
in the day when you would watch USC in
that case he said you guys remember most
people would just stand they would just
go toe to toe again would swing it was
just a big it was all wrong yeah I mean
I'll be it like I guess like for most
people when people saw like the ground
game developed they got really bored
they would start booing stuff but at the
same time there's people for example
like Daniel Cormier
he's almost undefeated one person only
beat him John Jones that's it and that's
because his ground game is so [ __ ]
incredible you know what I mean and that
just shows like how important that [ __ ]
is like he wasn't me like when I watch
like Daniel Cormier fight I get a little
bit bored but at the same time I can't
knock the guys like technicality and
skill because you can't take him down
the guy took Rumble Johnson Albion he
was considered one of the best
pound-for-pound fighters in his weight
class pick them up and slammed him like
he was a [ __ ] bitch-ass paperweight I
should blew my mind oh I forgot what I
was watching but for two minutes
straight this guy was getting his dick
punched Oh old school he had a minute
crucifixions yeah yeah and I was like
what the hell is that old UFC how small
school everyday
shamrock days right what caused the fire
I wasn't even nut buster
no no no it wasn't us you didn't exist
no some of your scene all right I was
your fear
that's hoist Gracie can shamrock that
kind of arrow right yeah
had the crucifix that he was elbowing
his face to death
Oh another one sock robber now would not
every go see yeah okay that [ __ ] I can't
why can't what I said blood starts
coming out even if it's like a cut right
above the eyebrow it's just too much for
me like yeah it's too intense it starts
with gush though it gets really crazy
there I and I feel like spitting in yeah
I like it because it's two consenting
adults that are down a throw down and be
warriors so like I I feel only as
sensitive as the person is so if someone
like let's say we have a daughter right
and she gets her cut and she's like
bleeding of course I feel really really
sad that's not her [ __ ] but I like let's
say or David's a [ __ ] insane warrior
and he's down and going [ __ ] go blow
to blow even though it's getting
pummeled I'm [ __ ] out David cuz I I
live here going through the fence on
watching hmm you watch and I mean I do
not watch any of these things I do not
do any gore I can't even watch Hunger
Games like that's scary to me I'm just
like really still watching
there is something about this like
animal tea watching two people it's so
proud of it it's very majority man you
watch do you guys what I do want it for
someone to get I watch it because I'm
just in awe of like the skill set that
because women in it now that are [ __ ]
good yeah
and women are badass but the ones that
women are better no no I said and the
women in there are they oh yeah and
women are badass okay so yeah so yeah I
find them to be pretty badass but they
want to get like they like I said the
blood and all that like I just feel it
and anything cuz I feel the pain I when
I watch movies yeah I'm not really when
I watched fighting so Kazan III thought
we wanted use the opposite movies are
fake this is a real life I know I know I
know anything for her the consent I
think she's saying like oh the consent
is like okay well they they're signing
up I could before eyes to watch the
female fights it would make me feel
weird too because they don't look as
good and they were kind of
prepare huh but now the women are
extremely prepared extremely athletic
and I'm like Dana what the [ __ ] did
getting themselves into they pop your
ass yeah it could be my eyes are
fighting on my parka
shit's so crazy yeah I do run off soon
as you change to the game yeah like
really flip the perspective on what a
female fighter is yeah now she's getting
her ass pummeled nationally this kind of
call fasting what's evolving though yeah
yeah yeah you already got to exploit the
best very fast you know some Brazilian
lesbian what's her name is friendliness
yeah oh she still on top yeah
a man in didn't don't do her boxing is
[ __ ] amazing that she has like it's
like a mother [ __ ] dude she's like a man
punching power
yeah she's [ __ ] what Miesha Tate ass
dude I mean she take one twice right she
beat rocky twice I was it one beat her
once
Oh Peter never Rossi came up super hard
she but she beat the one that beat me
home to be loyal to the one hours ago
yeah Oh Holly Holmes is dope too hey
guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out of here
[Music]